while hundreds of thousands of Voters
had been expected at polling stations
across the swatini pro-democracy
activist zodram contest stayed away she
belongs to the People's United
Democratic movement an opposition group
that the government declared a terrorist
organization
Qantas says it's because of its
criticism of iswatini's absolute
monarchy Parliament is meant to be a
people's institution where their voices
must be heard and it is what they say
that must take precedence in anything
our our voting therefore is useless
because it doesn't give people any
rights you can now start voting people
have been voting for representatives of
parliament's lower house which serves in
an advisory role to Kingdom Swati III
he's ruled for 37 years and has the
power to dissolve parliament and veto
laws but the government says this is an
opportunity for people's voices to be
heard they need the representation they
need their services and they have to
make their lives and their welfare
better and that is why they have to
organize around their constituences and
get their voices heard and have a part
in the National policy through their
representative we would love to make a
distinction between the monarchy and the
people that the people of eswatini do
have a say
protests in 2021 and 2022 calling for
democratic reform
an afro-barometer survey suggests 59 of
the population once political parties
legalized so that they can have a say in
the government
less than a third of eligible voters
turned out at the previous election in
2018 but first-time voter Mayu Bongo
similani says it's an opportunity for
change I think this is important for
young people to vote because they can
express themselves from what they they
want the nation to do for them as they
are the young people
yeah such as
maybe school fees if they can afford
okay homes
maybe infrastructure
people are choosing 59 MPS with a
further tin appointed by the king its
likely results will be announced over
the weekend but many say whoever wins a
seat in Parliament is not likely to
change much given that previous members
who voiced descent or suggested reform
were jailed familiar Al Jazeera and
babani swatini
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera